did you have a Cabbage Patch can no my
my brother my younger brother he was
like four years younger than so he was
into all that you know how people like
you want to smoke weed out of an app or
whatever we could we could not find
anything to smoke weed out we had a good
[__] bud and we could not find
anything to smoke weed out and the preey
if you remember it had this little tough
of hair and had a pacifier yep right so
uh my brother goes what if we use this
and I'm like what are you talking about
and he pulls the tough the hair out and
then he [__] pokes a into where the
pacifier is and we smoked weed out of a
Cabbage Patch baby's head Perfect Dude
somebody should make a p out of that so
good it works so good